2021년 10월, 마크 저커버그는 무대에 올라와서 인터넷의 다음 시대에 대한 거대한 청사진을 내놓습니다.
페이스북은 이제 메타가 되고 앞으로의 인터넷은 메타버스 안에서 펼쳐질 거라고 말하죠.
메타의 공식 창업자 서한에서 저커버그는 앞으로 10년 안에 메타버스 이용자가 10억 명에 도달하고
수천억 달러 규모의 디지털 상거래를 만들고 수백만 명의 창작자와 개발자를 먹여 살릴 수 있다고 했습니다.
말 그대로 회사 이름 전체를 미래에 걸어버린 순간이었습니다.
지금 돌아보면 너무 과장돼 보이지만 당시에는 이 말이 꽤 진지하게 받아들여졌습니다.
미국에서는 누군가가 스눕독의 메타버스 이웃이 되기 위해 약 45만 달러를 냈고
디센트럴랜드에서는 가상 부지가 240만 달러에 거래됐습니다.
한국도 예외가 아니었습니다.
서울 전역을 잘게 쪼갠 디지털 땅을 파는 세컨서울에는 한 달도 안 돼 25만 명이 몰렸고
한국 투자자들 역시 어스2 같은
플랫폼에서 서울의 디지털 땅을 선점하듯 대거사들이며 이 열풍에 올라탔습니다.
그러니까 메타버스의 시작은 단순한 기술뉴스가 아니었습니다.
그건 미래의 인터넷, 차세대 부동산, 새로운 소비공간, 새로운 투자 기회가 한꺼번에 포개진 거대한 서사였습니다.
그리고 오늘 이야기하려는 건 바로 그 서사가 왜 그렇게 빠르게 부풀었고
또 왜 그렇게 허무하게 식어버렸는가 입니다.
메타버스를 이해할 때 가장 중요한 건 사람들이 처음부터 제품을 믿은 게 아니라
약속을 믿었다는 점입니다.
당시 메타가 내놓은 건 완성된 생활공간이 아니라
일하고, 놀고, 쇼핑하고, 친구를 만나고, 공연을 보는 다음 인터넷의 청사진이었습니다.
그리고 그 약속이 힘을 가질 수 있었던 건
당시의 시장 분위기가 그 이야기를 받아들일 준비가 돼 있었기 때문입니다.
맥앤디는 메타버스가 2030년까지 최대 5조 달러의 가치를 만들 수 있다고 했고
시티는 많게는 50억 명이 쓰는 거대한 시장이 열릴 수 있다고 전망했습니다.
2021년 3분기 모든 기업들의 실적 발표에서
메타버스라는 단어가 449번 등장했다는 집계까지 나왔습니다.
기업들 입장에서는 이걸 비웃기보다 혹시 안 올라탔다가
뒤처지는 건 아닐까를 먼저 걱정하게 되는 분위기였던 겁니다.
여기에 저금리와 넘치는 유동성, NFT와 크립토 열풍까지 겹쳤습니다.
그 시절엔 실체가 조금 부족해도 서사만큼이면 투자와 관심이 먼저 붙던 시기였습니다.
그래서 사람들이 가상공간에서 돈을 쓰면서
그래서 사람들이 가상공간에서 돈을 쓰면서 돈을 쓰면서
디지털 자산을 사고 아바타를 꾸미며 살아갈 것이라는 말이
아주 황당하게 들리지는 않았던 시기였던 겁니다.
그래서 메타버스는 단순히 저커버그 한 사람의 과장된 비전으로만 커진 게 아니었습니다.
컨설턴트들은 거대한 숫자를 붙였고 투자자들은 다음 플랫폼이 될 수 있다고 믿었고
기업들은 혹시라도 흐름을 놓칠까 봐 앞다퉈 관련 전략을 꺼내들었습니다.
메타버스는 한 회사가 만든 허상이라기보다
저금리와 과잉기대, 미래산업에 대한 조급함이 함께 만들어졌습니다.
집단적 열광에 훨씬 가까웠던 겁니다.
물론 한국도 이런 열풍을 놓칠 리가 없습니다.
미래라는 말이 붙고 돈이 몰리기 시작하면
늘 가장 먼저 반응하는 시장이 한국 아니겠습니까?
세컨서울은 서울 지도를 가상 부동산처럼 쪼개서
강남역, 광화문, 한남도열 같은 현실의 비싼 주소를
가상세계에서도 선점할 수 있다는 식으로 사람들을 끌어모았습니다.
현실 부동산 청역처럼 줄을 서는 심리가 가상공간으로 그대로 옮겨간 셈입니다.
그런데 나중에 알고 보니까
론칭 전에 97억 1,600만원 규모 타일이 관계자들에서 사전 배분된 사실이 드러났고
그렇게 뜨거웠던 서비스는 오래 버티지 못했습니다.
버스트도 크게 다르지 않았습니다.
사람들은 실제로 들어가 살 수도 없고
임대 수익이 보장된 것도 아닌데
디지털 자표를 사고 팔면서
가상 강남당 선점, 가상 청와대 매입, 초기진입 프리미엄 같은 이야기를 진지하게 나눴습니다.
지금 돌아보면 황당해 보이지만
그때는 이런 말조차 꽤 그럴듯하게 들리던 시기였다는 겁니다.
그만큼 한국에서도 메타버스는 기술보다 먼저 투자와 소유의 언어로 소비됐던 겁니다.
그런데 바로 이 지점에서 이상한 장면이 나타납니다.
시장은 메타버스를 미래라고 믿기 시작했고
투자자들과 기업들은 앞다퉈 그 서사 위에 올라탔습니다.
그런데 정작 그 열풍의 중심이던 메타가 실제로 내놓은 공간은
사람들이 상상했던 미래와는 꽤 달랐습니다.
기대는 이미 하늘로 올라가 있는데
막상 제품은 그 기대를 받쳐주지 못했던 겁니다.
대표 서비스인 호라이즌월드는
2022년 내부 문서 기준 월간 이용자가 20만 명에도 못 미쳤고
원래 50만 명이던 연말 목표는 28만 명으로 낮아졌습니다.
메타버스의 문제는 그래픽이 조금 별로였다는 정도가 아니었습니다.
사람들에게 헤드셋을 쓰고 굳이 들어가서
오래 머물 이유를 만들지 못했다는 게 핵심이었죠.
친구를 만나기엔 인스타그램과 카톡이 더 편했고
게임을 하기엔 이미 더 재밌는 게임이 많았고
일을 하기엔 줌과 슬랙이 더 효율적이었습니다.
심지어 아바타 다리조차 제대로 구현하지 못해
조롱을 받았고 다리 시연 영상마저
모션 캡처 기반 연출이었다는 보도가 나왔습니다.
정말 심각한 건 이용자 수보다 손실입니다.
리얼리티랩스의 연간 영업 손실은
2019년 45억 달러, 20년 66억 달러,
21년 102억 달러, 22년 137억 달러,
23년 161억 달러, 24년 177억 달러,
25년에는 192억 달러에 가까운 손실을 냈습니다.
다 합치면 2019년부터 2025년까지 약 881억 달러입니다.
쉽게 말해서 메타는 사람들이 거의 머물지 않는 가상세계에
천문학적인 돈을 계속 쏟아부은 셈입니다.
그리고 지금 메타가 힘을 짓는 곳은 더 이상 메타버스가 아닙니다.
2015년 스케일 AI에 143억 달러를 투자해 알렉산더 왕을 데려왔고
2026년 4월에는 새 슈퍼인텔리전트 팀의 첫 모델인 뮤즈 스파크를 공개했습니다.
이제 시장이 더 궁금해하는 건 메타버스의 부활이 아니라
메타가 AI 경쟁에서 오픈 AI와 구글, 엔트로픽을 어디까지 떠나는가?
따라 붙을 수 있느냐는 쪽입니다.
투자 방향을 보면 더 확실해집니다.
메타는 2025년 자본지출로 722억 2천만 달러를 썼고
2026년에는 1150억에서 1450억 달러까지 늘리겠다고 했습니다.
공식 실적 자료에 따르면 이 증가부는
메타 슈퍼인텔리전스 랩스와 AI 인프라 핵심 산업을 지원하기 위한 투자입니다.
같은 시기 메타는 호라이즌 생태계의 초점을 모바일 중심으로 재편한다고 밝혔고
리얼리티 랩스 손실은 2026년에도
2025년과 비슷한 수준일 거라고 전망했습니다.
즉 회사의 이름은 아직 메타지만
회사의 실제 미래 설명서는 이미 AI 중심으로 다시 쓰이고 있는 겁니다.
물론 메타만 이렇게 방향을 틀고 있는 것도 아닙니다.
디즈니는 2023년 메타버스 전략 구설을 없앴고
월마트도 로블럭스 안에서 만들었던 유니버스 오브 플레이를 6개월 만에 닫았습니다.
한국에서는 SK텔레콤의 이프랜드가 2025년 3월 31일 종료됐고
KT도 메타라운지와 지니버스를
2014년에 정리했습니다.
네이버의 재패토는 완전히 접지는 않았지만
최근에는 순수 메타버스 서사보다
AI 스트리머와 아바타 기반 콘텐츠 쪽으로 반전의 실마리를 찾고 있습니다.
롯데의 칼리버스 역시 사업을 이어가고는 있지만
투자금의 약 56%가 손상 차선으로 반영될 만큼
기대치가 크게 낮아진 상태입니다.
한때 다음 인터넷이라던 사업들이 몇 년도 못 버티고 접거나 축소된 겁니다.
그래도 메타가 진짜 다행이었던 건
메타버스는 엄청난 실마리를 받았고
메타의 SNS 본업은 여전히 엄청난 돈을 벌고 있었습니다.
메타의 2025년 전체 매출은
그 중 리얼리티 랩스 매출은
돈의 대부분은 결국 페이스북, 인스타그램, 왓츠앱, 메신저에서 나왔습니다.
한마디로 메타버스는 돈을 태웠고
SNS는 그 손실을 버텨낼 현금을 벌어준 셈입니다.
그런데 최근에는 바로 그 메타를 지탱해주던 수익 구조에도 균열이 생기고 있습니다.
SNS는 전체 매출은 29억 7천만 달러였는데
SNS가 너무 잘 돌아간 덕분에 돈은 벌었지만
그만큼 중독성과 청소년 보호 문제를 둘러싼 법적 리스크도 함께 커지고 있는 겁니다.
세부 사건은 각각 다르지만 핵심은 비슷합니다.
메타의 플랫폼이 사람을 오래 붙잡아두는 데는 성공했지만
그 과정에서 발생한 사회적 비용과 책임 문제가
이제 본격적으로 돌아오기 시작했다는 점입니다.
메타버스는 아무도 원하지 않아서 실패했고
SNS는 너무 많은 사람이 너무 오래 써서 리스크가 커진 셈입니다.
그래서 지금 메타버스는
지금 메타의 AI 비벗은 단순히 요즘 AI가 유행하니까 수준으로 볼 일이 아닙니다.
메타버스는 미래를 약속했지만 수요를 만들어내지 못했고
SNS는 수익을 만들었지만 중독성과 규제, 소송이라는 비용이 커지고 있습니다.
이런 상황에서 AI는 메타에게 새로운 성장 서사이자
동시에 다음 수익 구조를 다시 설계해야 하는 절박한 베팅일 수 있습니다.
메타버스는 끝났습니다.
하지만 메타의 진짜 다음 승부는 이제부터 시작입니다.
영상 시청해 주셔서 감사합니다.